[Music]
hi I'm John cusumano and I'm a super
duper World Cup fan this is my ninth
World Cup I went to the first one in mid
Italy in 1990 and I've taken my three
sons to all of them and now I'm taking
grandchildren
and we love it
I'm very blessed to have
been able to do this with him and my
family it's a wonderful way for us to
connect I'm excited every four years I
don't love soccer traditionally but
I mean I love it when I come here
[Music]
I played it as a child I played it in
school I coach my three sons in soccer
started the soccer league in St Louis
Missouri where we're from USA and it's
just been a part of our Lives just a
really exciting thing to be able to do
with your father well he was my soccer
coach when I was growing up it was more
than just a sport it was a bonding
experience for a bunch of kids to just
grow up with and cherish forever foreign
[Music]
could experience the joy and the peace
competition
but still uh respect for the game and
respect for people
[Music]
sadly earlier this year he was in the
hospital like three times and so I was
hesitant to even book this whole trip
and then as As Time marched on we're
like well you know what I think we got
to go so we did it I would crawl if I
hit
and you know I'm a proud man however uh
even a little humiliating to have my
sons and grandsons push me around here
in my little cart
but I can take it because I'm uh the
World Cup means that much to me right
now I'm going to try and live long
enough to go to the next one
it'll be our tent
World Cups with my sons and my
granddaughter
and my grandchildren but life is good
foreign
[Applause]